he's he's a a crazy like he's an
engineer right like i built i once um
i'm in a key i go to ikea and i made uh
you built a playhouse for me no i didn't
it's a tree house without a tree that
didn't end up in a tree there was no
tree there's just on the ground it was
on the ground it wasn't a house it was a
box it was a square four pieces of wood
nailed together
but here so that's me yeah i go jeff
dunham has a studio not far from where
we're doing this you know what he built
a helicopter no you didn't did you
really four of them actually three and a
half
real ones that fly i pulled that up you
started this podcast saying you weren't
good at anything
no i'm not talking about a model
helicopter i'm talking about the kind
you see in traffic jeff dunham
helicopter see what comes up your
helicopter
you don't helicopter accident oh look
look at that but now get real ones don't
let's go to the real real world those
are models those there's the yellow
one's real right yeah but those are
those aren't garbage
you don't trust ones you can buy did you
have a helicopter oh the real ones yeah
i didn't have a copter accident no get
together to my helicopter wait wait is
it on the right is it that it wrote away
elite no no no no none of these no there
it is there i am kneeling next to it no
the green one
the green helicopter the wait uh you
were just there there there the red
white and blue that right there i
painted it right after 9 11. wow you
built this wow and that flies oh yeah
here i built that right after 9 11 so
that's why that weird paint job with the
paint ripping off did you paint that no
i did not i told the guy i wanted
military green from the uk and he did
from
vietnam
oh like no
that's what's wrong with it yeah that's
it so where is that helicopter today at
my uh uh hangar in camarillo
how many you have all four helicopters
no no what happened was i built i built
this one no i'm sorry i built one and
then i flew it for a few hundred hours
and they came out with a better kit and
i built the second one and sold the
first one yes it comes in a box well it
comes in like 60 boxes you read the
instructions are you not concerned about
things you like just me if i wouldn't
get into anything i built i'm i'm scared
to sit on this chair i assembled it i
went to staples i got this chair and i
had to put the wheels on the bottom and
it'll a little is a little unnerving
because the first thing you do is when
you take it to altitude which means two
three thousand feet is you pretty much
shut the engine down and make sure you
can land it with the engine off crazy
you could from 2000 feet without an
engine yeah you can land it yeah you can
land a helicopter one time with no
engine
one time yeah is it a landing so you
crashed you said you crashed well i
crashed when i was practicing doing that
did you get hurt well how do you
practice doing something one time
it's called an auto rotation and it'll
you can any helicopter the engine goes
out you can land it but you didn't but
just like an airplane the engine goes
out you can land an airplane no
it has a like a wingspan and you feel i
feel like an airplane can glide yeah i
feel like this is a mosquito dropping
we're like the podcasts that talk about
helicopter accidents and flying right
isn't this the third guest we've had
that's talked about flying helicopters
and crashing and stuff yeah if i could
ask you how many uh dummies do you have
wait wait i want to go back
so you drop down did you get hurt oh no
what i was doing was i could do it with
my eyes closed just about i was just i
can crash with my eyes close too yeah i
was in texas in the middle of a corn
field and i just got disoriented and
thought the wind was up my nose and it
was at my tail and that's a bad thing
and i rolled it over you didn't even
know which way the wow and you walked
away
yeah that's good not not happy so you
built that and then three months later i
had i rebuilt it and had it flying again
and what i did was my buddy told me at
the time he goes you need to auto rotate
down to the exact spot that you crashed
and because i have memories so crazy you
know when i crashed i hit my head on the
fire extinguisher and bent my ray-bans
and they fell in the dirt because the
helicopter was on its side and so i
picked up the
put them in the case and i said to
myself as i was hanging from the harness
i'm going to come back here and and
straighten these sunglasses back out and
my buddy goes you should auto rotate to
that very spot straighten the sunglasses
out there and i did that and three
months later i went out by myself i auto
rotated down to that spot landed right
where i crashed pulled the
sunglasses out of the box straighten
them up dusted them off put them on and
flip off into the sunset if ray-ban is
listening anybody from ray-ban what a
great little integration we just had
oh boy it sounds dangerous man it sounds
good no because they're like because
once you straighten them out they'll
hold on to your ears and as long as the
glass
in the lenses isn't burnt
but and that's why he's where he is
today
[Music]